How very clumsy of me!
One fine morning, a young click beetle decided to go for a walk.
In the afternoon, it rummaged through a pile of pebbles.
I'm king of the mountain!
In the evening, it crawled among the tall blades of grass.
I can see my burrow from here!
And when it turned night, the young click beetle crept up a tree.
After a while, it got tired and fell to the ground.
It landed on its back.
The young click beetle tried very hard to turn over onto its feet.
But it couldn't.
Help! Help!
All along, a wise old click beetle had been watching the young click beetle.
Tomorrow morning, I will teach you how to click and flip through the air and land on your feet.
In the meantime, you might as well go to sleep.
Good night!
The next morning, the wise old click beetle said,...
"Look at me."
"This is how it is done."
It flipped through the air and landed on its feet.
Now, you try it.
Thank you.
That looks easy.
Look at me!
It flipped through the air but it landed on its back.
How very clumsy of me!
Just then, a turtle ambled by.
Better luck next time.
Keep on trying!
"Look at me!"...
...said the young click beetle.
It flipped through the air but landed on its back.
How very clumsy of me!
"You'll get there,"...
...said the snail.
Look at me!
It flipped through the air but it landed on its back.
Just then,...
"Quick! Click and flip!"...
...cried the wise old click beetle who is watching.
But this time, it did three graceful somersaults and landed on its feet.
Look at you!
You have done it!